on va revenir sur cette affaire sur
cette terrible agression raciste qui a
eu lieu vendredi dernier à villecraine
dans le Val de Marne un homme de 75 ans
a copieusement insulté mourade un
jardinier qui est en train de travailler
qui bloquait sans le vouloir une impasse
avec sa camionnette de travail en plus
des insultes racistes l'agresseur va
sortir un cuteur et trancher la gorge de
de Moktar sur 15 cm la scène a été
filmée à la fois par par Mourad
directement par Mourad et vous allez
voir ça dans un instant mais également
par une caméra de vidéosurveillance la
vidéo est folle mais
je v vous dire Mourad il est tellement
gentil ouais l'attitude c'est ça le truc
c'est qu'en fait je crois que c'est
aussi vous allez voir la vidéo en vrai
il est tellement gentil voilà avec le le
gars que le gars il il prend la
confiance et surtout ce qui se passe
c'est que le gars il est il est libre là
actuellement ah oui AB c'est un truc de
fou donc vous allez nous dire ce que
vous en pensez êtes-vous choqué le
suspect remis en liberté les gars c'est
n'importe
quoi je vais dire ce que j'en pense dans
un instant et je vais encore avoir des
problèmes avec avec mes amis mais mais
je m'en fous total c'est inadmissible ça
regardez
regardez les bouou je suis chez moi Bou
ouis les bouou
je suis chez
moi dég retour chez
toi tomber laisse
tomber
alors bon on on a vu cette vidéo tourné
toute la journée ce qui est fou et moi
quand j'ai vu cette vidéo je suis sûr
que vous avez pensé à la même chose que
moi je me suis dit qu'est-ce qui se
serait passé l'utre sens s c'était dans
l'autre sens et c'est vrai que je me
suis mis à la place je vous dis la
vérité je me suis mis à la place de
Mourad et c'est vrai que mourade il il a
dû se dire c'est une personne âgée
qu'est-ce que je fais il est resté euh
limite voilà il prenait pas trop trop au
sérieux et résultat il s'est fait
trancher la gorge sur 15 cm si ça avait
été le contraire imaginez imaginez le
tolé que ça aurait fait imaginez même si
ça pas été le contraire si Mourad après
les différentes insultes qu'a proféré ce
monsieur il l' aurait dit il l'aurait
poussé ù il aurait dit écoute calme-toi
parce que je vais te mettre une tarte je
sais pas voilà n'importe quoi juste s
les voil exactement prends juste
l'inverse tu prends deux Français qui
sont deux blancs parce que c'est un
blanc et tu prends un arabe qui vient
pour essayer de trancher la gorge au
deux Français non mais là c'est ah c'est
fini mec on le revoit plus alors RA
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est un truc de fou cette histoire
écoutez trois jardiniers qui bossaient
chez une cliente et un individu qui
voulait absolument circuler avec son
véhicule
ouais il a été tout de suite agressif on
a vu je sais pas si on voit sur ces
images là mais on a vu des des images
sur les réseaux sociaux l'individu a
commencé par dégrader il a pris un
cuteur dans son véhicule il a dégradé le
véhicule des jardiniers et
ensuite c'est là que le drame commence
et
l'individu s'en prend à une remorque il
voulait la dégrader aussi et à ce
moment-là il met il tente de mettre un
cuteur un coup de cuteur au niveau du
visage à la victime cette dernière
l'esquive et ensuite il met un deuxième
coup de cuteur au niveau de la gorge et
là il lu ouvre carrément rendez compte
mais imaginez non mais je vous dis
imagine est même la même scène qui est
filmée où Mourad insulte ce ce ce ce ce
ce vieux monsieur où à mon avis c'est
c'est c'est incroyable cette histoire et
là ce qui se passe et qui rend fou tout
le monde c'est que aujourd'hui le
suspect poursuivi pour un jour non publi
en raison de l'origine l'ethnie la
nation la race ou la religion
dégradation volonaire de bien d'autru
causant un dommage léger et violence
avec usage ou menace d'une arme euh
pourquoi cela n'a pas été qualifié en
tentative d'homicide pour motif raciste
c'est ça je comprends pas moi g on
comprend pas c'est que dès le départ il
est interpellé par la BAC il est déféré
et dès le départ la tentative d'omicide
est écartée alors qu'à 1 cm près c'était
la
carotinde il était Mor jeis vous dire
mais c'est ça qui est parce que le même
mec je te dis la vérité moi j'ai des
potes à moi il parle comme ça à un
poteah il va prendre une tarte voilà et
et c'est vrai voilà direct et ça aurait
été le contraire et lui il est tellement
gentil Mo il fait rien il se dit c'est
il a 75 ans voilà non mais c'est ça qui
est fou mais il y a pire encore il y a
pire encore c'estàdire que il est jugé
en comparition immédiate pour violence
volontaire avec armes et le parquet de
créta dit quand même là il faut le
mettre en détention provisoire et le
juge des libertés de la détention dit
pas du tout pas du tout simple contrôle
judiciaire et il sera jugé le 16 mai et
on apprend aujourd'hui que ce retraité
là c'est un
multirécidiviste et alors c'est Monsieur
Darmanin qui l'a dit je vais vous dire
ce qu'il a fait outrage à policier
dégradation refus d'obtempérer déjà un
jure non public en raison de la race et
de la religion donc il a un casier
monumental et il est en liberté non mais
c'est
incroable même au niveau je va vous dire
même au niveau du buzz je vous dis
franchement ça aurait été le contraire
ça aurait été un buzz mais tout le monde
en aurait parlé tout le monde en aurait
fait des caisses et des caisses et je
trouve pas que ça ait fait un buzz
incroyable je suis désolé he là tu
aurais eu tu aurais eu à l'Assemblée
nationale tu aurais eu tout le monde si
la francemis'en est beaucoup emparé
d'ailleurs il ne parle que de ce fait
divers qui est atroce et le problème
c'est encore une fois c'est pas la
police c'est la justice mais que fout la
justice dans ce pays enfin c'est
le parquet le parquet voulait la
réquisition detenstion exemp c'est le
juge des libertés jug des
Libert on attend qu'il égorge vraiment
quelqu'un il a 76 ans il a la je suppose
peut-être il faut pas le faire mais je
vais vous dire maintenant ce qui va se
passer c'est que voilà ça va ça va tout
de suite dégénérer bah c'est sûr demain
demain tu as un mec même de 75 ans qui
va insulter un autre gar il va dire moi
je vais je vais tout de suite voilà par
que sinon bien sûr c'est un signal
catastrophique tous guettter le procès
de mai parce qu'il risque 3 ans qu'ison
et je voudrais bien savoir ce qu'il va
prendre il ris théoriquement 3 ans de PR
là il dort tranquille chez lui là oui
alors c'est un peu on a appris enfin
c'est on va
pas il y a toujours une enquête en cours
mais en fait il a apparemment il a des
très très gros ennuis de santé hein des
questions de vie privée je peux pas trop
rentrer dans les détails et c'est dû à
son âge que si enfin c'est pas la police
hein comme vous l'avez dit la police
pour le coup a fait son
TF
la police on a dit la police a très bien
travaillé on a rien dit sur la police
c'est juste qu' on s'étonne je je vais
vous dire même la police croyez qu's
sont pas dégoûtés les policiers ils vont
chercher gar not quotidien ouais mais
c'est insupportable le gars tu vas à
quoi ça sert alors qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire com moi j'ai plein de j'ai plein
de potes moi ils me disent qu'est-ce que
tu vas je vais aller faire des
interventions je vais me faire chier
aller faire des interventions je sais
très bien que le gars il va sortir dans
24 heures qu'est-ce que jeux je vais
perdre mon temps je vais prendre un
risque donc malgré les ennuis de santé
ce qui me dérange moi en tant que
représentant du personnel c'est que on a
aurait pu très bien pourquoi pas une
détention provisoire et comme on l'a
fait comme on l'a fait dans l'affaire
pierre palmat j'étais venu sur ce
plateaul ben le mettre le soigner à
l'hôpital et avec moi je dire Mo je vais
dire un truc moi les ennuis de santé de
ce gars Mourad il Mourad il en a rien à
taper lui aujourd'hui il a été ouvert de
15 cm mour il en a rien à taper le gars
soit très malade ou unuc comme ça mais
je te dis le mec c'est quoi ça regardez
d'ailleurs mourade a filmé également il
a filmé le l'autre vidéo également
regarde complètement cinglé
lui
malade ici et nous on est des bounoules
nous ouais ah ouais c'est comme ça que
vous parlez ouis mets mets un coup de
cur mets un coup de cur vas-y met vas-y
vas-y mets un coup de C je che moi i non
laisse-le laisse-le laisse-le laisse
laisse tu vas voir toi laiss je suis
chez moi tu fais quoi là je suis chez
moi la je filme laissle je le filme non
laisse-le laisse-le laisse-le mal
laisse-le tout est filmé tout est filmé
ouais vas-y vas-y pr ici
vas-y il a quand même de la force qui
est malheureux c'est que il pense se
protéger en se filmant alors qu'au final
il est pas protégé et c'est ça qu'il fut
les boule quand on voit la vidéo c'est
que ser rienit vidé mais me est
de filé pour l'assurance il avait peur
que il a filmé pour film aussi pour
protéger Mo moi aussi parce qu'il s dit
moment si ça dé et que moi viens fra
gars au moins qu'on sache ce qu'il a
fait avant parce que je t'explique ça
aurait été on n pas la vidéo et c'est M
qui lui met une Chifou un truc comme ça
le lendemain c'est l'autre qui vient
porter plainte et y a un mec qui m' qui
m'a tapé il y a Mo qui m'a tapé et
derrière c'est tout le monde qui semmène
et c'est trucs et mour a taper un vieux
de 76 ans et ça y est c'est parti ça
part en cacahuète totale je vous
dire je vous dis moi moi ça ça me rend
fou je te jure r je sais pas comment tu
fais parce que vraiment je sais pas
comment tu fais je sais pas pas comment
vous faites
vous les policiers les mecs qui qui les
gendarmes franchement je sais pas
comment vous faites pour garder votre
calme et pour continuer à faire ce que
vous faites quand on voit ce qui se
passe derrière je suis désolé moi je te
dis que ça me rend fou que ce mec soit
encore dehors ce mec qu'est-ce t sa ce
soir peut-être plus est malade ce so il
s on a parlé la semaine dernière avec le
collègue qui était tré sur 20 m qui est
policier donc investi d' mission de
service public véhicule volé mineur de
17 ans qui son aujourd'hui à 18 ans le
collègue il a pris il a 30 jours d'ITT
il a toujours pas repris le travail il
est traumatisé psychologiquement et à
côté de ça le gars il a pris 35 jours de
tige imaginez ça veut dire le signal
c'est quoi dans certaines
circonscriptions c'est je mets une gifle
à un policier je mets un coup de cuteur
à quelqu'un qui essaie de faire un
gars sign et on s'étonne après qu'il y a
des mecs qui arrivent dans une fête avec
des couteaux de FAM et qui poignar tout
le monde ils ont pas peur la vie elle
coûte plus rien maintenant ils ont pas
peur il dit je vais poignarder un mec je
vais passer au tribunal on va me dire
bon bah il a échappé miraculeusement à
une blessure très grave avec une
entaille de 15 cm sous le menton parce
que là c'était fini la car c fin un
miracle c'est un miracle c'est veut
mourir mais en plus c'est ça que j' je
vois l'attitude du gars et je le vois
très bien je le comprends très bien
Mourad s dit quoi il s'est dit c'est
c'est un vieux monsieur ça va tu vois
voilà et en fait et voilà et et le pire
c'est qu'il a eu il a été respectueux
limite voilà ça le faisait pas marrer
mais bon voilà avec ses collègues et
cetera et et voilà bah je vous dis et
donc il çaait ça aurait été un mec plus
méchant bah peut-être qu'il aurait pas
pris le le coup de cuteur c'est ça qui
est fou c'est ça qui est fou donc
parfois quand tu es quand tu es trop
gentil ben voilà bah tu te retrouves
avec une entaille de 15 cm donc voilà
donc je vous dis c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est incroyable franchement je
sais pas comment tu fais mon r va